mit der bundeskanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten die sich da
versammelt haben in berlin das ganze
wird übrigens auch für gehörlose in der
rechts oben im fenster übersetzt und
sobald die pressekonferenz beginnt geben
wir den ton ab
sie sehen an der konstellation der
pressekonferenz ja dass wir uns in einer
besonderen phase befinden einer
geschäftsführenden bundesregierung einer
entstehenden neuen bundesregierung und
das drückt sich auch jetzt hier in
dieser pressekonferenz aus aber wir
haben diese konferenz auch im
bewusstsein abgehalten dass es dem
währungs vollkommen egal ist ob
deutschland sich gerade in einer phase
mit geschäftsführender bundesregierung
befindet oder verhandlungen zur bildung
einer neuen stattfinden und es ist ihm
auch egal wer sich wie weit schon in
seinen politischen überzeugungen bewegt
hat sondern entscheiden tut nur was
diebe richtigen und wichtigen maßnahmen
sind und deshalb war heute das einzige
kriterium unserer beratung auch dass wir
mitten in der vierten welle uns mit der
aktuellen dramatischen
infektions situation in deutschland
befassen und daraus die möglichst besten
schlussfolgerungen ziehen das betrifft
zum einen die eindämmung des
exponentiellen anstieg und das betrifft
zum anderen das schnelle impfen im
zusammenhang mit der
auffrischungsimpfung zum ersten muss man
sagen dass wir eine wirklich
besorgniserregende situation haben die
es nicht in deutschland gleich verteilt
sondern zwischen den bundesländern gibt
es eine inzidenz spanne von 117 bis
911 aber tatsache ist dass die
bundesweite verdopplung zeit jetzt 13
tage betrug und die verdopplung zeit der
belegung von intensivbetten etwa 23 24
tage und wir wissen damit dass wir uns
eine weitere verdopplung zeit bei der
belegung von intensivbetten nicht
erlauben können das heißt wir brauchen
einen schnellen
stopp oder einbremsen des exponentiellen
steaks und dem dienen alle beschlüsse
die wir heute gefasst haben natürlich
dient dem auch wenn es darüber
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt das
infektionsschutzgesetz was jetzt heute
im deutschen bundestag und
verabschiedet wurde und morgen im
bundesrat beraten wurde wir wissen und
das ist bedauerlich wir könnten besser
dastehen wenn die impflücken nicht so
groß wäre und deshalb werden viele
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen werden
müssen nicht notwendig gewesen denn wer
mehr geimpfte menschen hätten und es ist
nie zu spät sich impfen zu lassen auch
jetzt kann man auch mit einer
erstimpfung einen guten beitrag für sich
und für die gemeinschaft leisten
bei den beschlüssen die wir heute
geschafft haben ging es also als erstes
um das impfen hier ist heute die
auffrischungsimpfung auch noch mal von
der ständigen impfkommission gewertet
worden und für alle empfohlen die älter
als 18 sind und zwischen fünf und sechs
monate zurückliegen nach der letzten im
nach der zweiten impfung das ist eine
gute nachricht weil da hat natürlich
auch für alle mehr sicherheit eintritt
aber es ist eine herausfordernde
nachricht weil nunmehr eine große zahl
von menschen
mit einer solchen auffrischungsimpfung
versehen werden muss das sind etwa noch
27 millionen impfungen wenn man überlegt
wie viele menschen bis zum 31 bis zum 30
juni
2021 schon geimpft waren vier millionen
haben wir schon das heißt 27 millionen
bleiben etwa übrig bund und länder
verpflichten sich jedem ein angebot zu
machen und das bedarf einer wirklichen
großen kraftanstrengung die
cds werden gemeinsam als chefs der
staatskanzleien wenn gemeinsam mit den
gesundheitsministern bis zur regulären
cds konferenz in der nächsten woche
eine planung vornehmen wie das geschehen
kann welche fragestellungen sich auftun
wo unterstützt werden muss der weg hat
das hofen schutz haben ihre
unterstützung heute auch angeboten und
wir werden dann versuchen hier wirklich
eine große sicherheit hinzubekommen es
wir haben uns befasst mit den
verschiedenen aspekten des lebens jetzt
will ich hier nicht alles da schon auch
im infektionsschutzgesetz geregelt ist
3g am arbeitsplatz die frage des
öffentlichen personennahverkehrs und
anderes aber ich will sagen ein großer
zweck der heutigen ministerpräsidenten
konferenz war wann muss muss das
instrumentarium angewendet werden dass
wir im infektionsschutzgesetz zur
verfügung haben und da haben wir heute
wie ich finde sehr sehr gute beschlüsse
gefasst wir haben nämlich schwellenwerte
definiert ab denen dann eine bestimmte
flächen deckende im maßnahmenkatalog
eingesetzt werden muss das beginnt bei
einem hospitalisierung index sie wissen
dass der für uns selbst die maßgebliche
größe ist vom 3 wenn der überschritten
wird dann muss zweig
flächendeckend eingeführt werden das
heißt also geimpft oder getestet bei den
gesamten veranstaltungen und ähnlich
geimpft und genesen entschuldigung ja
und bei einem schwellenwert von 6 beim
hospitalisierung index wird das ergänzt
durch zweig plus das heißt auch die
geimpften und genesen müssen getestet
werden und wenn der hospitalisierung
index neuen überschreitet da geht es
dann vorbehaltlich der zustimmung der
landtage natürlich weil die dann
sozusagen oder auch notwendig sind nach
der konstruktion des jetzigen
infektionsschutzgesetzes bei einem
schwellenwert von über 9 beim
hospitalisierung index muss dann das
gesamte instrumentarium der
möglichkeiten eingesetzt werden kontakt
beschränkungen und verschiedene
einschränkungen
hier ist ja kein geheimnis bin ich der
meinung dass dieser katalog nicht
ausreicht aber wir haben dann auch eine
vereinbarung getroffen auf die hervis
noch näher eingehen wird das im lauf der
zeit ja die dinge auch wieder überprüft
werden können und es ist sehr gut dass
im infektionsschutzgesetz enthalten ist
eine regelung dass bis zum 15 dezember
das ist insbesondere für sachsen jetzt
sehr wichtig maßnahmen die jetzt noch
eingeführt werden auch dann gelten
können ist es wichtig dass bürger test
kostenlos natürlich angeboten werden und
wir haben uns noch einmal auch bereit
erklärt dass wir bei den pflegekräften
im zusammenhang mit der intensivpflege
insbesondere einen bonus zahlen werden
und wir haben heute eine vereinbarung
getroffen die
eine die eine länder bitte ist nämlich
dass das personal in pflegeeinrichtungen
geimpft sein soll das heißt also hier
wird der bund in kürze befinden die wir
uns zu verhalten
aber das ist natürlich eine sehr
wichtige mitteilung alles in allem haben
wir damit heute einen ganz großen
maßnahmenkatalog die ich finde
verabredet ich sage allerdings die lage
ist hochdramatisch und es wird jetzt
sehr darauf ankommen dass schnell
gehandelt wird das konsequent gehandelt
wird das besser kontrolliert wird und
dann wird man beobachten müssen ob wir
die dynamik damit stoppen oder zumindest
reduzieren können weil der jetzigen
dynamik laufen wir in eine sehr sehr
schwierige situation rein insbesondere
für alle menschen die in krankenhäusern
und insbesondere in der intensiv medizin
arbeiten wir haben immer gesagt wir
wollen unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordern wir wissen dass wir das
heute nicht flächendeckend einhalten
können glücklicherweise haben wir noch
an einigen an vielen stellen kapazitäten
aber es ist wirklich
absolute zeit zum handeln und deshalb
war diese mbk heute not nicht und wir
werden permanent beobachten müssen ob
das was wir beschlossen haben reicht
oder ob wir doch zu einer noch
schwierigeren situation kommen was ich
nicht hoffe und es wird jetzt von jedem
auch abhängen sich an die dinge zu
halten ich kann dazu nur auffordern denn
wir sind in einer sehr ernsten situation
herr ministerpräsident höchst
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren der
gesundheitsschutz hat unsere absolute
priorität und gemessen an dem ziel ist
die lage sehr ernst die stimme der
einschätzung der bundeskanzlerin
uneingeschränkt zu seit elf tagen
täglich ein neuer rekordwert an
neuinfektionen die inzidenz liegt in
deutschland bei über 330
tendenz steigend wir müssen uns klar
machen was diese entwicklung bedeutet
für gestern wurden welt 65.000
neuinfektionen von diesen menschen
werden ohne dass wir heute noch einen
einfluss darauf haben viele hundert
menschen
sterben und das gilt genauso für die tag
davor dafür und für den heutigen tag
wir sind in dieser pandemie sehr sehr
nahe an dem punkt an dem wir nie kommen
wollten dass in deutschen krankenhäusern
entschieden werden muss wenn man noch
behandeln kann und unser oberstes gebot
muss sein diesen notstand mit allen zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln zu
verhindern die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger hat absoluten
vorrang das ist das wichtigste das ist
aktuell das entscheidende und darum war
es so wichtig und so gut dass bund und
länder heute endlich zusammen gekommen
sind wir waren in der pandemie immer
dann am stärksten wenn man gemeinsam
agiert hat wenn man geschlossen agiert
hat gemeinsames geschlossenes vorgehen
schafft akzeptanz und vertrauen beides
werden wir in den kommenden wochen noch
brauchen ich bin sehr froh dass dieses
verständnis dieser geist die heutigen
beratungen
geprägt hat der dreiklang heißt vorsicht
impfen testen bund und länder sind
deshalb bereit zu einer fläche nden
flächendeckenden anwendung von 2g zweig
plus und weiteren maßnahmen wenn es die
hospitalisierung since it ends in drei
schritten 369 erfordert die länder sind
darüber hinaus bereit und entschlossen
zu einer massiven ausweitung der booster
impfung und alle länder halten eine
impfpflicht in heilberufen mitarbeiter
mitarbeitern krankenhäuser und
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe
für
erforderlich weil dort mit wohlhabenden
menschen umgegangen wird im einzelnen
wir setzen jetzt bundesweit ab eine
hospitalisierung rate von 3 und
freizeitbereich auf zweige regeln bei
einem wert von 6 auf 2 g + regeln unter
einem wert von 9 in abstimmung mit den
landtagen so sieht es das
infektionsschutzgesetz dann ja vor auch
auf weitere maßnahmen auch am
arbeitsplatz brauchen wir mit der 3g
regel ein deutlich höheres schutzniveau
das gleiche gilt für den psv den
regional- und
fernverkehr für personen die nicht
geimpft werden können für personen für
die keine allgemeine impfempfehlung
vorliegt und für kinder und jugendliche
bis 18 gelten natürlich ausnahmen wir
sind einig dass der vollzug deutlich
gestärkt werden muss wir brauchen
strikte kontrollen von ihm gelesen und
fest nachweisen
um die vierte welle brechen zu können
brauchen wir jetzt erneut einen
nationalen kraftakt beim impfen wir
werden daher unsere im kapazitäten
massiv und flächendeckend ausbauen
nachdem wir in den pflege- und
altenheimen mit dem fußball angefangen
haben wollen wir nun allen menschen
frühestens nach dem fünften monat ein
angebot für eine auffrischungsimpfung
machen
zusätzlich zum regelsystem der hausärzte
werden alle länder ihre
impfmöglichkeiten massiv ausweiten wir
waren uns auch einig dass wir
vor allen dingen mit diesem vorgehen die
verwundbarsten stärker schützen müssen
deswegen halten im übrigen auch alle
länder für erforderlich da gab es eine
große einigkeit dass wir ein sichtungs
bezogen angehörige von heyl und
pflegeberufen mitarbeiter mit der beiden
krankenhäusern sowie einrichtungen der
eingliederungshilfe
pflichtig impfen lassen wollen also
erstmals eine impfpflicht
zum testen testen bedeutet zusätzliche
vorsicht und vorsorge für sich selbst
und für andere deshalb ist richtig dass
es die schnelltests wieder überall
kostenlos gibt insbesondere für menschen
mit kleinem geldbeutel eine wichtige
zusätzliche schutz optionen
auch durch tests müssen wir das
schutzniveau für die verwundbarsten
deutlich erhöhen gerade in alten- und
pflegeheim
pflegepersonal insbesondere auf den
intensivstationen leistet in diesen
tagen wieder
großartiges ihnen allen danke ich im
namen aller ministerpräsident den
ministerpräsidenten und der menschen in
unserem land für ihren unermüdlichen
einsatz
wir wollen es mit blick auf die
besondere belastung des pflegepersonals
aber nicht bei dankesworten belassen
deswegen erneut eine pflege bonus
parallel zu den heutigen beratung hat
der bundestag eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes beschlossen die
morgen im bundesrat beraten wird dazu
möchte ich für die b länder sagen dass
wir weiterhin einen ausreichenden
instrumentenkasten für erforderlich
halten es ist aus unserer
überzeugung es ist ja bekannt als
falsche signal die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite auslaufen zu lassen
ihre verlängerung werde das beste und
rechts sicherste mittel gewesen aus
unserer sicht brauchen wir auch über den
fünfzehnter dezember hinaus die
notwendigen instrumente zur bekämpfung
von regionalen hotspots um die menschen
bestmöglich zu schützen es kann aus
sicht der ländern der länder gerade die
auch heute schon besonders hoch die
zahlen haben nicht sein dass in extremen
hotspots die schließung von
gastronomischen betrieben in einer
region nicht blicken der flächendeckend
möglich ist wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse zeigen dass gerade da die
meisten infektionen entstehen und zwar
wichtig dass wir heute eine zusage vom
bund erhalten dass der
instrumentenkasten das des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
spätestens mitte dezember evaluiert wird
diese zusage haben wir heute vom
bundesfinanzminister erhalten für den
fall dass einer von ihm angeführten
bundesregierung wird spätestens bei der
pk am 9 dezember bewertet ob die
maßnahmen ausreichend sind und es werden
gegebenenfalls auch kurzfristig
änderungen vorgenommen für mich und die
unionsgeführten länder steht fest als
regierung eines landes muss sich in
jedem moment für den fall eines falles
voll handlungsfähig sein um die menschen
zu schützen deshalb ist diese
evaluierungs klausel die wie sie heute
vereinbart haben wichtig und ich danke
dafür ausdrücklich und schluss möchte
ich ganz herzlich danke schön sagen
allen bürgerinnen und bürgern die sich
ihre liebsten und andere haben durch
eine impfung schützen
lassen alle bislang ungeimpften
bürgerinnen und bürger bitte ich erneut
sich solidarisch zu zeigen und sich
zügig impfen zu lassen nur so werden wir
die pandemie effektiv bekämpfen vielen
dank herr
regierender bürgermeister müller bitter
wir sind mitten in einer vierten welle
sie hat uns voll getroffen und die
auswirkungen sind dramatisch da gibt es
nichts drumherum zureden zu beginn der
woche war ich mit den beiden chefs der
landeseigenen kliniken in einer
pressekonferenz und sie haben in aller
klarheit geschildert wo wir stehen ja
und berichtet von verzweifelten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in der
charité und vivantes von den bitteren
momenten denn auch junge menschen
versterben die ungeimpft sind schwangere
dabei sie haben berichtet was es für
eine physische und die belastung ist
über wochen und monate
diese schwerst erkrankten auf den
intensivstationen zu sehen sind also in
einer dramatischen situation
aber das will ich hinzufügen noch nicht
weil nichts passiert ist es ist viel
passiert in den letzten monaten wir
haben mit vielen maßnahmen mit vielen
entschlossenen maßnahmen die wir
umgesetzt haben bund und länder auf
vielen menschen geholfen die haben viel
leben auch gerettet
das ist aber auch klar dass wir fest
davon ausgegangen sind dass wir jetzt in
diesen tagen schon eine höhere impfquote
haben können erinnere immer wieder daran
wie wir doch so darauf gehofft haben ein
medikament oder eine impf möglichkeit zu
haben zu beginn der pandemie und wir
doch eigentlich im ernst alle
miteinander nicht damit gerechnet haben
dass es so schnell gehen könnte ein
impfstoff zur verfügung zu haben wir
hatten ihn dann schnell zur verfügung
wir haben ihn eingesetzt wir haben die
elf zentren aufgebaut im stellen mobile
teams wir sind vor ort gewesen in kinos
shopping malls auf öffentlichen plätzen
und haben viele menschen impfen können
aber die impfquote es eindeutig zu
niedrig sind immer noch rund 25
millionen menschen in unserem land die
nicht geimpft sind selbst wenn man die
abzieht die sich noch nicht impfen
lassen können ist die impfquote immer
noch zu niedrig ist und zu viele
menschen die die impf angebote nicht
annehmen obwohl sie es tun könnten
lisa an der stelle auch bleibe dabei
meiner meinung es liegt nicht daran dass
es zu wenig aufklärung gegeben hat in
den letzten monaten zu wenig werben zu
wenig impfmöglichkeiten zu wenig
infrastruktur zu wenig geld zu wenig
impfstoffe oder zu wenig
entschlossenheit ist nicht der grund
sondern der grund ist dass es zu viel
egoismus und zu viel gleichgültigkeit
gibt es tatsächlich einige immer noch
der meinung sind in dieser
solidargemeinschaft kommt es auf ihr
verhalten nicht an und doch es kommt auf
ihre halten an sich und andere zu
schützen ist lebens ist
überlebensnotwendig
das muss man so klar sagen
und insofern werden wir natürlich auch
weiter werben wir hatten weiter angebote
machen alle bundesländer überall hier
haben wir es eben geschildert wurde
heute miteinander beschlossen die
angebote deutlich auszubauen die
impfzentren die impfstellen es wird
weiter die mobilen teams geben
selbstverständlich wir werden weiter und
personal werben um noch schneller auch
die auffrischungsimpfung anbieten zu
können alles richtig aber genauso
richtig ist es jetzt auch deutlich zu
machen dass es nicht ewig so weitergehen
kann dass eine minderheit eine mehrheit
dominiert und deren gesundheit gefährdet
und dass wir jetzt auch entschlossen die
2g regeln umsetzen oder auch zwei gpus
es war wichtig dass wir uns heute
zwischen bund und ländern auf diesen
fahrplan wie er beschrieben wurde
verständigen konnten mit den
entsprechenden
grenzen die dann zu zwei g2 gps oder
doch darüber hinausgehenden maßnahmen
führen glaube dass das nötig ist und
dass es viele menschen gibt die
inzwischen auch darauf warten dass sie
als genesen und geimpfte auch die
möglichkeit haben weiterdingen anspruch
nehmen zu können und das andere die sich
nicht impfen lassen eben auch damit
leben müssen dass sie nicht mehr so
uneingeschränkt zugang zu vielen
lebenssituationen haben oder andere
beschränkungen kauf nehmen müssen oder
sich eben auch testen lassen müssen oder
andere maßnahmen hinnehmen müssen ja
meine damen und herren ich glaube dass
jenseits dieses hoch fans der im
kapazitäten die wir uns vorgenommen
haben und die 2g regeln ist auch wichtig
ist dass wir noch mal klar gesagt haben
dass es strenge tests pflichten gibt in
den pflegeheimen in den medizinischen
einrichtungen natürlich auch um die
betroffenen die dort sind und die die
schutzlosesten sind dass wir sie so gut
es geht eben doch auch schützen können
mit diesen maßnahmen ich glaube dass es
ein wichtiges signal dass wir uns heute
darauf verständigt haben schleunigst wir
bestimmte berufsgruppen einrichtungs
bezogene im pflichten im bauch in
angriff zu nehmen dass das
vorangetrieben werden muss und ich will
auch noch hinzufügen abschließend dass
ich darauf setzte dass wir natürlich den
maßnahmenkatalog den wir haben durch den
beschluss des deutschen bundestages auch
in den ländern entschlossen umsetzen
denn wir haben einen weitgehenden
maßnahmenkatalog zur verfügung wir
hatten in den letzten wochen zur
verfügung viele die beklagen dass manche
dinge nicht umgesetzt worden sind hätten
es tun können in eigener verantwortung
auch für die nächsten wochen ist das
noch möglich und gerade diese nächsten
wochen sind auch entscheidend für die
frage wie wir über dezember und januar
kommen dafür hat uns der bundestag mit
seinen beschlüssen die entsprechenden
möglichkeiten gegeben und insofern setze
ich auch darauf dass es jetzt jenseits
von möglicherweise
ansprüche die die eine seite an die
andere seite hat einfach dazu kommt dass
wir jetzt auch wirklich
konstruktiv mit dieser beschlusslage
umgehen ich will mich den dank den herr
wüst eben angesprochenen ausgesprochen
hat ausdrücklich anschließen den dank an
so viele wenn ich mich anschließen die
solidarisch in den letzten monaten waren
so viel mitgetragen haben so besonnen
verhalten haben und sich und andere
geschützt haben und ich will diesen dank
aber auch nochmal mit einem deutlichen
appell verbinden sich jetzt nicht
zurückzulehnen sondern dass alle noch
einmal mit helfen entweder jetzt wenn
sie es noch nicht getan haben angebote
annehmen die angebote annehmen zur
dritten impfung zu dieser
auffrischungsimpfung und ja jetzt in
dieser phase wo so viele angebot
hoffentlich auch annehmen kann es zu
wartezeiten kommen ich bitte dafür um
verständnis wir werden alles tun um so
schnell wie möglich auf dieser info
angebote besser und schneller umsetzen
zu können
aber bitte warten sie nicht einfach
darauf in den nächsten wochen sondern
bemühen sie sich jetzt um diese
auffrischung
und bemühen sie sich jetzt um termine
jeder tag zählt
und ich möchte auch noch den appell
formulieren dass wir jenseits von impfen
erster und zweiter und
auffrischungsimpfung auch weiter daran
denken uns an regeln zu halten es wird
wichtig bleiben auch mit einer impfung
wird das wichtig bleiben auf abstand
hygiene auf maske tragen auf all diese
regeln weiter zu achten um wie gesagt
nicht nur uns selbst sondern andere zu
schützen danke herr minister scholz
unser land befindet sich in einer neuen
quelle die paris infektion nehmen mit
großer geschwindigkeit zu wir merken
dass es eine wachsende belastung gibt
auf den intensivstationen und das ist
etwas was wir uns alle gerne erspart
hätte
klar ist dass viele sich jetzt sorgen
machen ängste neu entstehen auch
erinnerung wieder hochkommen an die
situation wie sie war im letzten winter
und in den anderen wählen die uns so
herausgefordert haben und deshalb ist es
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir uns jetzt
unterhaken des werks land gemeinsam
handeln und all die notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen und die schritte
unternehmen die wichtig sind um die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger zu
schützen jeder für sich aber auch wir
uns alle gemeinsam
deshalb ist es gut dass wir jetzt eine
reihe von maßnahmen unternehmen können
die mit den neuen gesetzgebung des
bundestages möglich geworden sind und es
ist sehr gut dass auch die
ministerpräsidenten konferenz zusammen
mit der bundesregierung jetzt konkrete
präzise beschlüsse gefasst hat über das
was jetzt zu tun ist damit wir gut durch
diesen winter kommen denn das ist genau
das was wichtig ist wir müssen jetzt die
monate die vor uns liegen wo die
infektion schon wegen der jahreszeit
wieder zunehmen werden als monate
betrachten in denen wir mit großer
geschwindigkeit die anstrengung auf den
weg bringen die wir jetzt brauchen dazu
zählt zuallererst dass sich diejenigen
impfen lassen die sich noch nicht haben
impfen lassen und mein appell ist dass
alle sich jetzt ein ruck geben und die
entscheidung für sich selber für ihre
liebsten für ihre angehörigen treffen
und es ist gut dass wir deshalb eine
solche ausweitung der impf angebote
bekommen in den arztpraxen aber auch mal
den öffentlichen angeboten mit mobilen
impfmöglichkeiten mit impfmöglichkeiten
in den neu eröffneten impfzentren es ist
wichtig dass wir
viele davon überzeugen dass sie sich
jetzt eine auffrischungsimpfung cohen
dann auch das hilft durch die pandemie
und es ist klar da geht es um millionen
denn viele haben sich ja schon ein und
zweimal impfen lassen und alleine wenn
diejenigen sich neu impfen lassen ein
drittes mal die jetzt so knapp sechs
monate seit der linsen im funk zurück
haben dann wird das bis zum jahresende
fast nicht ganz 30 millionen
auffrischungsimpfungen umfassen das zu
organisieren das möglich zu machen das
ist eine große anstrengung die alle
miteinander vor sich nehmen müssen
überall in den städten und gemeinden in
deutschland in den landkreisen in den
ländern und wir müssen das jetzt
organisieren dazu hat sich die
ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz verabredet
dazu ist die bundesregierung
entschlossen und dazu sind die
grundlagen mit den entscheidungen des
bundestages auch getroffen worden wir
werden um durch den winter zu kommen
einschneidende maßnahmen sehen die es
bisher nicht gegeben hat ich will das
noch mal in erinnerung gerufen wir
werden an den arbeitsplätzen die 3g
regelung umsetzen weil angesichts der
tatsache dass so viele sich haben impfen
lassen und das für alle die möglichkeit
besteht sich impfen zu lassen dass auch
jetzt die konkret mögliche und richtige
maßnahme zum schutz aller bürgerinnen
und bürger ist aber es ist ein schritt
und weitreichender schritt das gleiche
gilt für die regelung die wir für den
öffentlichen verkehr getroffen haben und
die der bundestag jetzt vorbereitet hat
auch das trägt zu größerer mehr
sicherheit in unserem
mein wunsch ist also dass wir alle das
jetzt als zeit nutzen in der wir zeigen
dass wir als land zusammenhalten können
das gilt für die bürgern und bürger und
dann darf man noch setzen dass viele das
auch miteinander machen werden und dass
sie ihren beitrag leisten werden aber
das gilt auch für uns alle die wir
verantwortung haben im öffentlichen
leben dieses landes dass das möglich ist
davon bin ich nach dem heutigen tag sehr
überzeugt dass wir eine gute beratung im
bundestag zwar eine gute beratung hier
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zwar
eine gute beratung zwischen der
bundesregierung und den regierungschefin
und regierungschefs der länder und ich
glaube so müssen wir weitermachen
vielen dank die erste frage kommt von
herrn feld von der ard
christian fällt die bericht aus berlin
eine frage zum thema kontrollen bei 2g
und 3g zunächst an sie frau
bundeskanzlerin
wann sind sie denn persönlich das letzte
mal zum beispiel im restaurant nach
ihrem zertifikat gefragt wurde und ganz
grundsätzlich gerne auch an den rest der
runde wie soll das gelingen das wirklich
überall das praktisch kontrolliert wird
dankeschön
also ich persönlich
bin sowieso nicht so viel da wegs aber
nach test bescheinigung bin ich schon
gefragt worden bei veranstaltungen die
das feuer angekündigt haben bei
restaurants oder ähnlichem habe ich den
eindruck als erzählung dass es einfach
noch viel zu wenig kontrolliert wird es
wird kann nie flächendeckend
kontrolliert werden aber es muss eine
systematik entstehen bei der jeder weiß
dass die gefahr einer kontrolle da ist
und dieses ist noch nicht überall
flächendeckend der fall gewesen aber ich
glaube jetzt haben alle ihre
entschlossenheit irgendwo auch deutlich
gemacht das war auch bei den ländern
heute spürbar dass das gewollt wird ich
war gestern auch beim deutschen
städtetag auch da ist inzwischen eine
große bereitschaft dafür da bei jeder
jasid war was los ist in den eigenen
krankenhäusern und das muss verwehrt
werden dass ich das so weiter entwickelt
wenn frau dunst
warten sie eine option
sie hat uns haben die explodierenden
infektionszahlen zeigen ja wie
dramatisch die große koalition und auch
die länder im bundestagswahljahr die
kontrolle über dieses virus verloren hat
und die ampel parteien herr scholz
wirken jetzt ja auch nicht gerade
überzeugen frau bundeskanzlerin wie
schwer tragen sie an diesem
vertrauensverlust in der bevölkerung und
wenn sie heute ganz frei ohne
ministerpräsidenten und herrn scholz
hätten entscheiden können was hätten sie
verfügt und herr scholz sie können im
gegensatz zu frau merkel nun lehren aus
fehlern ziehen es wirkt ja absurd bei
diesen zahlen die pandemische lage
auslaufen zu lassen warum haben sie es
nicht verhindert ist das der preis für
eine regierung mit der fdp
also von meiner seite werde ich sagen
wir haben anfang august also bereits im
wahlkampf ja eine
mpk gehabt die einige maßnahmen
festgelegt hat insbesondere das 3g wir
haben damals keine mehrheit für zwei wie
gehabt das bedaure ich hatte das damals
schon als eine möglichkeit gerne ins
auge gefasst heute hat der die
entwicklung dazu beigetragen dass das
natürlich jetzt ganz normal erscheint
und ganz sinnvolle august gab es darüber
noch lange diskussionen ob man solche
radikalen maßnahmen machen kann und wir
ich hätte auch gerne dieser entwickler
etwas früher gehabt aber da will ich
jetzt nicht lange drüber nachdenken der
instrumentenkasten ist bei den ländern
natürlich zur verfügung gewesen und die
frage wann man handelt ist vielleicht
immer noch ein bisschen davon getragen
dass die dramatik exponentiellen
wachstums über das ich oft gesprochen
hat habe manchmal unterschätzt wird
jetzt haben wir aber sozusagen uns hier
zusammengefunden und was ich mir
gewünscht hätte ist dass wenn schon die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite abgeschafft werden muss was
mir überhaupt nicht einleuchtet was ihr
psychologisches signal auch immer für
falsch gehalten habe aber wenn das schon
sein muss dann hätte ich mir wenigstens
gewünscht dass die länder den gleichen
katalog zur verfügung haben wie er
bisher im 28 da ist ausgenommen die
ausgangssperren sage ich ganz deutlich
und ausgenommen die frage der
flächendeckenden schulschließung beides
wollen wir nicht aber es gibt eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen die jetzt nicht in
diesem infektionsschutzgesetz wie es
jetzt ist da sind wir brauchen uns nicht
eben über epidemischen lager so dazu
unterhalten jetzt können die länder dann
auch machen aber den maßnahmenkatalog
hätte ich mehr umfassender gewünscht
es ist gut dass wir hier zu gemeinsamen
ergebnissen gekommen sind und dadurch
werden jetzt entscheidungen auf den weg
gebracht die schnell zügig ergriffen
werden überall in deutschland darum geht
es ja das geschieht jetzt auch zu einem
zeitpunkt wo es darauf ankommt und es
wird nicht stück für stück geschehen
sondern gewissermaßen in einem großen
grund einer großen anstrengung die
überall in deutschland jetzt unternommen
wird das ist glaube ich ein ganz großer
vorzug vor früheren situationen wo viele
vielleicht gezögert haben wurden
unterschiedlichen stellen deutschlands
unterschiedliche maßnahmen ergriffen
worden sind jetzt sehe ich schon das mal
abgesehen von den auswirkungen des der
unterschiedlichen
lage beim infektionsgeschehen trotzdem
hier gemeinsam gegangen ich will nur
sagen zweig wird jetzt überall gemacht
dass es die konsequenz der verabredung
wir haben all die neuen möglichkeiten
die mit den sehr scharfen regeln der
gesetzgeber geschaffen hat verbunden
sind und das wird auch dazu beitragen
dass wir besser durch diese situation
kommen also hier ist jetzt die grundlage
für gemeinsames handeln und auch dafür
dass alle ihrer verantwortung gerecht
werden und ich bin auch überzeugt werden
dass herr blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin können sie uns
erklären und dem sport fans hier gilt
zweig jetzt auch auf dem fußballplatz
für fußballprofis sollen unter punkt
acht heißt es das 2g auch gelte für
sportveranstaltungen und aus übungen
also es entsteht die frage ob jetzt
künftig sportprofis ungeimpft noch
fußball spielen dürfen und die frage an
herrn wüst sie haben sich dazu heute
nicht geäußert wie verhalten sie sich
denn morgen im bundesrat wird nordrhein
westfalen gegen das
infektionsschutzgesetz die ampel
vorschläge dazu stimmen und die
verhalten sich die unionsgeführten
länder insgesamt danke
zu dem infektionsschutzgesetz muss ich
mal an dieser stelle verweisen auf den
bundesfinanzminister der glaube ich
intensiver als verhandelt hat also
normalerweise ist es so dass die
arbeitswelt
3gs
und
nicht dort zweig verhängt wird auch wenn
in dem bundesland der schwellenwert
3000 ali sierung überschritten wird zwei
gilt dann sozusagen für alles was nicht
die arbeitswelt ist und jetzt kommt es
darauf an ob
das die arbeitswelt ist oder ob es
sozusagen wie freizeit welt ist so
verstehe ich darf aber ich bin
weder jurist dann noch wenn ich mich mit
dieser spezifischen sache intensiv
befasst notfalls muss nachrechnen also
alle fälle ist es so dass wir hier einen
so großen katalog haben vom master
üblich sind
das mal auf sie alle jetzt mit dem
gesetz im einzelnen beschrieben sind und
das wird eine ganz große veränderung mit
sich bringt das wird auch die nächsten
tage ihre berichterstattung ist wir
kriegen wenn ich das noch viel höher
sein weil natürlich gegenwärtig erst mal
und das ist völlig in ordnung diskutiert
worden ist was geht denn was wird
gemacht was kommt der wein oder sind
einzelne fragen dann im mittelstand
gewesen tatsächlich wird es aber so sein
dass hier ein sehr umfassender und auch
in vielen fällen weiter reichender
handlungskatalog zur verfügung steht als
der bisher zur verfügung stand und
gleichzeitig ist es so dass hier auch
noch die verabredung wird verbunden ist
weite teile davon auch jetzt schon aktiv
umzusetzen
ansonsten hat die kanzlerin ist trotz
der einschränkung für sie vorgenommen
hat sehr präzise geschrieben es gibt
regeln und für freizeitveranstaltung da
sind beschränkungen möglich wenn sie vor
ort jeweils gegriffen werden dazu ist
aber auch nur ist auch die 2g vorgesehen
für die teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
dass es ja damit verbunden und
selbstverständlich bedeutet das auch
dass dann für die teile diejenigen die
hier berufstätig sind die regeln gelten
die für den arbeitsplatz gelten die
länder haben natürlich die möglichkeit
beides zusammen zu führen wenn sie das
zu einer einheitlichen veranstaltung
machen das ist aber eine entscheidung
die dann vor ort zu treffen ist
sie haben mich nicht gefragt ich will
trotzdem noch angehen habe in der
vorbesprechung der länder chefinnen und
chefs waren wir uns sehr schnell einig
dass wenn zuschauer im stadion zweig
beachten müssen dass das nach unserer
auffassung auch für die profis gelten
soll und die rechtslage war klar ob wir
das umgesetzt gegen müssen wir jetzt
prüfen aber das war einhellige
auffassung der ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsident wird jetzt zum nicht
adressierten teil ihrer frage ich werde
jetzt im lichte der ergebnisse dieses
tages mit dem papier natürlich die
abstimmung in der nordrhein
westfälischen landesregierung
suchen und dann werden wir wie es in
viereinhalb jahren guter zusammenarbeit
immer gewesen ist in nordrhein westfalen
eine gemeinsame linie für morgen finden
sie haben ja jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten sich darauf
verständigt eine impfpflicht für
bestimmte berufsgruppen
einzuführen dem haben ja wenn alle
zugestimmt haben auch die
landesregierungen mit fdp beteiligung
zugestimmt herr scholz was bedeutet das
denn jetzt für die meinungsfindung
innerhalb ihre zukünftigen möglichen
zukünftigen koalition sie haben ja
jüngst auch gesagt dass sie das
eigentlich befürworten dass man in die
diskussion eingestiegen ist wie schnell
kommt diese impfpflicht jetzt die
mehrheit im bundesrat haben sie ja schon
dann die bundesregierung sich
einvernehmlich mit den ländern auf
diesen text verständigt kann man daraus
entnehmen dass diese aufgeschlossenheit
sehr weitreichend ist und auch in die
nächste regierung hinein reicht insofern
ist jetzt der prozess eröffnet für eine
gesetzgebung zu dem thema man sieht an
der tatsache dass wir die formulierung
im einzelnen fünf mal hin und her
gewendet haben die jetzt in dem
beschluss steht dass da auch noch
richtig gesetzgebungsarbeit und auch
öffentliche anhörung dazu notwendig sind
wie man das erwarten macht aber mit dem
beschluss der hier getroffen worden es
mit der
entscheidung der koalition über der
künftigen koalition eine diskussion
darüber zu eröffnen ist natürlich auch
vorgegeben dass am ende dabei auch etwas
herauskommt und ich befürworte dass wie
ich ja schon gesagt habe ich halte das
auch für richtig und ich bin sehr froh
darüber dass wir jetzt eigentlich in
einer situation sind wo
gesellschaftliche konsens die auch
politik werden und zwar schnell und
zügig möglich sind die man sich vor
einem jahr und vor einem halben jahr
nicht hätte vorstellen können ich greift
nochmals an das thema 3g am arbeitsplatz
die frage von
entsprechenden regeln für den von den
regeln für den öffentlichen verkehr wo
wir gesagt haben auch da müssen
entsprechende vorschriften beachtet
werden und natürlich gilt das auch für
die frage der durchsetzung von in
voraussetzung für berufliche tätigkeiten
in bereichen wo menschen gefährdet sind
wenn sie von jemandem infiziert werden
können und genau das ist hier in
beschluss angelegt und ich befürworte
sehr dass das jetzt der fall ist und
meine haltung ist mir klar und die
geschäftsführerin wir wollten nur sagen
geschäftsführende bundesregierung dass
der bundesgesundheitsminister wird euch
jedwede hilfe leisten eingeläutet wird
das bei der gesetzgebung lösen wird da
muss man also jetzt nicht 14 tage gar
nichts tun wenn das gewollt wird das da
ist jetzt das startsignal gesetzt durch
die politischen debatten die vorher
stattgefunden haben und zu denen ich
mich ja verhalten haben und durch die
entscheidung heute ist glaube ich noch
mal ein richtiger schritt nach vorne
gemacht worden und mein eindruck ist es
findet eine sehr breite zustimmung
wie gala in der letzten reihe
kontakt nina haase deutsche welle frau
bundeskanzlerin ich muss einfach diese
gelegenheit nutzen um ihnen eine frage
zur außenpolitik zu stellen wie
reagieren sie denn auf die
veröffentlichung des diplomatischen
briefwechsels zwischen den
außenministern von deutschland
frankreich und russland durch die
russische seite hinsichtlich des
normandie formats die französische seite
hat sich schon geäußert und hat gesagt
das ist durchaus nicht
diplomatisch gang und gäbe dass
normandie format ist ihnen ja eine
herzensangelegenheit also ihre reaktion
würde uns
erklären ich habe mich den ganzen tag
mit gesundheitspolitik beschäftigt klar
die russische seite hat den
diplomatischen briefwechsel zwischen den
außenministern heiko maas atrium und
darauf öffentlich gemacht über sputnik
wirklich 25 seiten detailliert eins zu
eins die briefe und herr lauf hat auch
argumentiert dass er die
veröffentlichung nutzen möchte um die
position der russischen seite
darzustellen warum es zu keinem treffen
bisher gekommen ist
ich meine dass briefe veröffentlicht
sind ist ja nicht jetzt so
überraschend dass ich lese viele meiner
brise im in einer zeitung
insofern hat man haben den sicherlich
keiner etwas zu verbergen aber die
tatsache warum es zu keinem
außenministertreffen gekommen ist die
wird mit sicherheit von französischer
und deutscher seite einerseits und
russischer seite vollkommen
unterschiedlich gesehen und ich habe das
immer in sehr bedauert ich habe da auch
den russischen präsidenten darum gebeten
dass gerade noch mit solange ich auch
bundeskanzlerin bin ein solches treffen
stattfindet ich hätte mir sogar ein
treffen auf chefebene gewünscht dass es
leider nicht zustande gekommen und
deshalb bedauere ich das sehr und daran
wird auch die veröffentlichung des
briefwechsels nichts ändern das meiner
meinung nach ein solches treffen hätte
stattfinden können denn wir dem mama die
heutige mpk wenn wir sagen würden weil
wir uns zehn tage vorher noch nicht
einig sind wie was genau das ergebnis
eines treffens ist und deshalb treffen
wir uns erst gar nicht dann würden wir
viel weniger resultate erreichen ein
solches treffen treffen haben immer eine
eigendynamik und deshalb sind sie gut
und wichtig und deshalb bedauerlich ist
dass es in letzter zeit zu solchen
treffen nicht gekommen ist
da die letzte frage von herrn rinke
reuters
keine frage die an die kanzlerin und
vizekanzler geht als vertreter des
bundes sie haben jetzt für 2g und zweige
plus schwellenwerte festgelegt für die
länder warum sitzen nicht den größeren
schritt gegangen und haben bei der
zweijährige zum beispiel eine
bundesweite regelung verhängt denn
dieser grenzwert von 3 ist so niedrig
dass doch eigentlich jedes bundesland
ich glaube bis auf bremen im moment
diese regelung sowieso schon einführen
muss also warum nicht der große schritt
wie wir das ja auch früher hatten das
bundesweit jetzt zweig eingeführt wird
und dann entsprechend auch zweig plus
das ist doch eine bundesweit
verständigung wenn man die kriterien
festlegt an die darüber entscheiden wann
man den jeweils nächsten schritt geht
und in deutschland steht im grundgesetz
dass die länder die gesetze des bundes
in eigener verantwortung ausführen wir
sind ein förderer des land mit einer
hohen verwaltungskompetenz deshalb
treffen wir uns zum beispiel in solchen
veranstaltungen wie dem gemeinsamen
treffen der bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder deshalb
gibt es die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
den bundesrat und alle die verabredung
aber das ist doch jetzt sehr weitgehend
eigentlich macht ihre frage doch
insofern auch einen guten sinn zum
abschluss wir haben uns untergehakt
deutschland handelt gemeinsam es gibt
klare kriterien wie wir entschieden
gegen die ausbreitung des corona virus
in deutschland weiter vorgehen wollen
wie wir die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger schützen wollen viele
bürgerinnen und bürger machen sich große
sorgen sie wollen dass wir das gemeinsam
lösen und gemeinsam anpacken und das ist
jetzt der schlusspunkt das ist etwas was
wir uns miteinander vorgenommen haben
und dazu gehören dann auch solche
weitreichenden strengen regeln wie wir
sie jetzt umsetzen ich glaube also dass
das heute ein guter tag war für den
zusammenhalt in deutschland ein guter
tag für eine aktive engagierte
bekämpfung der gesundheitsgefahren die
von dem corona virus ausgehen und es
sollte auch weiter so gehen wir müssen
das gemeinsam hinbekommen und wir werden
das auch gemeinsam hinbekommen uns in
dieser situation
auf einen weg zu begeben wie wir es
hinbekommen dass die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen bürger geschützt hat also
ich glaube das war wirklich ein guter
tag und ich will das auch noch mal sehr
persönlich sagen viele bürger und bürger
sind besorgt sie machen sich engst sie
haben ängste sie wissen nicht was da
passieren wird und deshalb ist es umso
wichtiger dass wir entschlossen und
gemeinsam hat das tun wir
genau 1 ist oft die wenigen monate der
bundes notbremse war das ja immer unsere
an uns mit dem ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten auf bestimmte
schwellenwerte zu einigen insofern ist
das in einer langen tradition der
pandemie bekämpfung eine gute botschaft
meiner meinung nach
danke ich das beschluss dokument hat
herr brücher für sie im schriftlich und
einen schönen abend noch dankeschön
erhard scherfer lassen sie uns kurz
darüber sprechen die gemeinsamkeit wurde
immer wieder hervorgehoben jetzt und sie
haben gestern gesagt der spannendere von
diesen zwei tagen heute und morgen ist
eigentlich der morgen im bundesrat und
ich fand jetzt die antwort von
ministerpräsident wüsten noch nicht so
ganz eindeutig glauben sie dass die
union morgen zustimmen wird im bundesrat
zum infektionsschutzgesetz oder nicht
naja glauben heißt ja nie wissen
irgendwie deswegen kann man nur ein
bisschen rätselraten beziehungsweise
sich die verschiedenen argumente die
dafür oder dagegen sprechen mal
gegeneinander halten und gegeneinander
abwägen und da würde ich im moment sagen
würde ich dazu neigen dass sie zustimmen
werden sie haben sich ja ein
hintertürchen offengehalten und sie
haben vor allem durch eine formulierung
die in dem beschluss dokument steht bzw
1 einen punkt den sie in den
verhandlungen heute herausgearbeitet
haben nämlich dass es am 9 dezember oder
spätestens bis mitte dezember eine
evaluierung der im moment angedachten
und geplanten maßnahmen geben soll
möglicherweise genau das hintertürchen
gefunden dass es hendrik wüst und
anderen die bislang und andere
ministerpräsidenten die wieso die
bislang dagegen gewesen sind gegen
dieses infektionsschutzgesetz zu sagen
dann wenn es in so kurzer zeit überprüft
werden wird dann können wir auch ja zu
stimmen besser als wenn wir jetzt gar
keine maßnahmen hätten und vielleicht
erhofft man sich auch in dieser zeit
noch einmal die ebene zukünftige ampel
koalition doch noch mal zu bearbeiten in
richtung fortschreibung oder weiter
heben feststellung der epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite auch das mag ein
argument sein ich denke unterm strich
wird es dann wahrscheinlich doch wenn
auch knapp eine zustimmung geben im
bundesrat für dieses gesetz ich würde es
zusätzlich begründen mit den punkten das
ja nicht alle ministerpräsidenten der
unionsgeführten länder dagegen gewesen
sind insofern könnte sich da eine
mehrheit finden für dieses für dieses
gesetz das heute im bundestag
verabschiedet worden ist aber ganz
sicher sein kann man natürlich bis
morgen um weiß ich nicht am frühen
mittag war dann sicherlich nicht nur 30
beginnt die bundesratssitzung wir sind
live dabei und dem muss man einfach
gucken wie sich das da entwickelt aber
wenn es so wird dann wäre es ja auch im
sinne sozusagen dieses der beschworenen
gemeinsamkeit aus dieser bund länder
runde eben lassen sie uns kurz die bund
länder runde aber doch noch mal
analysieren
impfungen alle ab 18 auch die dritte
impfung
das bedeutet im prinzip es wird ja enorm
viel geimpft werden müssen in nächster
nähe es derzeit eigentlich müssten in
diesen minuten jetzt schon die bauten
von neun impfzentren beginnen haben sie
das beobachtet dass da auch schon
wirklich aktivitäten gestartet wurden
vielleicht muss man mal gucken was die
gesamt beschlusslage ist von dieser
heutigen runde und das ist ja eine
mischung aus dingen die ich eigentlich
längst hätten stattfinden können wofür
man diese runde gar nicht gebraucht
hätte oder die man schon vor vier wochen
hätte beschlossen beschließen können als
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
das letzte mal zusammen
sind also auch da hätte man sich die
lage nicht so dramatisch viel besser als
heute zwar noch etwas aber eben noch
nicht besonders viel ich muss eine
kleine zwischen anmerkung machen ich
höre meinen eigenen ton irgendwie über
meinen ohrhörer mit wieder ist irgendwo
im mikro habe ich auf da müssen wir mal
was unternehmen dann kann man sich
nämlich besser konzentrieren auf das was
man hier eigentlich sagen will also man
hätte viele von den entscheidungen die
heute getroffen worden sind durchaus
schon vor einiger zeit treffen können
eben gerade was das impfen angeht dass
wir eine bestimmte impfquote brauchen um
einigermaßen sicher durch oder in den
herbst überhaupt hinein zu kommen das
ist ja eine erkenntnis die sj anderthalb
jahre alt beziehungsweise so alt wie der
zeitpunkt von dem man weiß dass das
impfmöglichkeiten gibt und das ist auch
durchaus erfolgreiche medien impfstoffe
gibt die dann auch helfen den menschen
in diesem land also da hätte ich schon
mal viel passieren können und die
bundeskanzlerin selber hat einen punkt
angesprochen nämlich das thema zweig
zugang nur für menschen also die
chinesen oder auch geimpft sind auch das
hätte man schon früher haben wollen
haben können das ist bei der letzten mpk
runde da bin ich nicht richtig erinnere
gescheitert an armin laschet der ist im
wahlkampf nicht haben wollte also vieles
von dem worauf man sich heute
verständigt hat hätte längst da sein
können hätte umgesetzt werden können
auch vieles aus dem alten
infektionsschutzgesetz kann immer noch
umgesetzt werden auch in den kommenden
wochen bis ungefähr ende november könnte
man das alles noch in kraft setzen und
das hätte wäre dann auch haltbar bis in
den dezember hinein also viele maßnahmen
durchaus greifbar was heute neu
dazugekommen ist es sicherlich der punkt
ab wann bestimmte maßnahmen die im
infektionsschutzgesetz stehen greifen
sollen das ist dieser hospitalisierung
werte index oder schwellenwerten nämlich
ab 3 dass das dann bei
freizeiteinrichtungen in der gastronomie
bei veranstaltung zu 2 geführt da sind
also ungeimpfte ausgeschlossen und das
ist bei dem hospitalisierung synnex 6
also das bedeutet sechs jan krone
erkrankte menschen die ihnen auf 100000
einwohner die ins krankenhaus müssen
wegen dieser infektion und das sogar
einen zeitraum von sieben tagen dann
gilt zweig plus also man muss entweder
genesen oder geimpft seien aber
zusätzlich noch einen test bei bringen
und ab dem sogenannten hospitalisierung
saxon 9 geht dann das komplette
instrumentarium das dann auch wieder zur
kontakt beschränkungen führen kann was
ja vorgesehen ist in dem im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz diese drei werte
oder diese drei zahlen die sind neu und
die waren auch schon mal in einer pk im
gespräch da konnte man sich nicht darauf
verständigen und hat sich zumindest
nicht auf zahlen verständigen können
oder wollen je nach dem vielleicht lag
es doch ein klein wenig im wahlkampf
aber an der stelle sind wir jedenfalls
ein bisschen schlauer als vorher und
sehen auch welche möglichkeiten
tatsächlich den ländern nach wie vor
gegeben sind es sei absolute zeit zu
handeln hat die bundeskanzlerin zum
schluss gesagt und sie werden jetzt
weiter überprüfen ob das auch wirklich
gemacht wird erst mal für heute vielen
dank erhard scherfer für diese analysen
und wir liebe zu schauen und zuschauer
wollen jetzt von den ministerpräsidenten
hören wie sie die veranstaltung die sie
ja auch eben beobachten konnten erlebt
haben und bewerten und der erste
ministerpräsident der sich gemeldet hat
ist aus bayern markus söder
wir stehen in bayern und deutschland vor
einem corona drama die zahlen
explodieren und zwar in kürzester zeit
die betten sind voll es droht eine
überlastung und es droht eine konkurrenz
nicht nur von kogit patienten auf den
intensivstationen
sondern auch von geimpften die eine ganz
normale erkrankung haben jetzt ist
moment vor allem sachsen bayern
thüringen und baden-württemberg
betroffen ist in der festen überzeugung
bald das ganze land die gründe dafür
sind eindeutig die impfquoten sind zu
niedrig und die impf durchbrüche zu hoch
und nicht
alles in dem moment überzeugt vom ernst
der lage wir müssen deswegen jetzt
verschärfen national wie bayerisch es
braucht einen wellenbrecher einen echten
wellenbrecher keine homöopathischen
dosen sondern eine maximale wirkung des
motto muss sein blocken und postern
glocken und postern ist das was ganz
entscheidend ist um sowohl das tempo der
ausbreitung
verlangsamen und umgekehrt in
schutzfaktor zu erhöhen
heute der bund sein neues gesetz
vorgestellt und beschlossen dieses
gesetz wurde vor der mpk gemacht dieses
gesetz ist ohne mitsprache der länder
entschieden worden dies ist in der
gesamten pandemie das erste mal der fall
gewesen dass man zuerst im bund
beschlossen und dann mit den ländern
geredet hat das war in der zeit von
angela merkel anders
die mpk konnte deswegen heute einige
punkte vereinbaren einige wichtige
punkte zum beispiel kunden in stara
verständigen einen pflege pony zu machen
2g flächendeckend in deutschland zu
verankern was wir in bayern haben und
auch was wichtig ist dem bund die zusage
abzuringen dass ausfälle beispielsweise
ausfallzahlungen für bestimmte maßnahmen
die getroffen werden müssten nach dem
gesetz doch erhöht werden
ich bin aber der festen überzeugung und
viele andere das gesetz das heute
beschlossen wurde ist der lage nicht
angemessen
ich glaube dass es nicht reichen wird
und ich bin sicher dass wir eine
wiedervorlage erleben werden mitte
dezember wird es so sein dieses gesetz
vom bund passt deswegen nicht weil die
lage wird täglich schlechter die zahl
der infektion erhöht sich aber die
instrumente sind weniger undeutlich
stumpfer gewonnen deswegen ist klar aus
meiner sicht es wird aufgrund der lage
in den nächsten wochen auf jeden fall an
gebessert werden müssen aber das gesetz
ist besser als nichts und es ist auch
viel besser als der erste entwurf es
wird ausdrücklich anerkannt von uns auch
von der staatsregierung dass zwischen
dem erstentwurf unter jetzigen
beschlussfassung vieles vieles
verbessert wurde deswegen ist für uns
auch klar wir werden im bundesrat
zustimmen diesem gesetz wir werden
dieses gesetz unterstützen
weil es eben eine grundlage ist noch
nicht ausreichend durch aber immerhin
und ich hielt es auch für falsch eine
blockade im bundesrat zu machen weil
jede form von zeitverzögerung am ende
der falsche weg wäre
bayern wird dann sofort reagieren wir
werden rechtlich versuchen alles
auszuschöpfen was möglich ist morgen
früh bereits habe ich die
koalitionspartner zusammengerufen und
wir werden schnellstmöglich dann die
entsprechenden neuen corona maßnahmen
auf den weg bringen können nicht weil
wir da freude daran hätten sondern weil
es zwingend notwendig ist aufgrund der
gesamten situation auch in bayern langes
warten ist schwierig ich werde übrigens
morgen nicht nur die koalitionspartner
zusammen rufen sondern am nachmittag
auch alle fünf partner weil um dieses
motto blocken und postern
zusammenzubringen wird morgen früh
geredet wie sozusagen geblockt werden
kann wellenbrecher etabliert werden
können und am nachmittag dann wie das
tempo beim boosten deutlich erhöht
werden kann mit all den maßnahmen die
dafür verantwortliche notwendig sind
anfang nächster woche geht es dann in
den landtag so dass bis spätestens mitte
nächster woche alle maßnahmen wirken es
macht auch deswegen sind zum einen weil
es für solche entscheidungen eine
parlamentarische legitimation braucht
und zum zweiten auch ein bisschen
einstellung auf das was kommen kann
ich will den maßnahmen nicht vorgreifen
die wir morgen beraten aber eines ist
klar es handelt sich natürlich um einen
de facto lockdown verunglimpfte dies
ergibt sich auch einfach durch den neu
veröffentlichten inzidenz zahlen
ungeimpfte haben in bayern eine inzidenz
von über 1500
kämpfte etwas über 100 ich weiß dass die
debatte um geimpften und ungeimpften das
land spaltet und die gesellschaft auch
und ich verstehe auch dass man auf alle
gefühle rücksicht nehmen muss auch auf
diejenigen die sich als ungeimpfte ein
bisschen an die wand gedrängt führen und
wir werben auch sehr dafür da noch
einmal brücken zu bauen und das ist
erkennbar dass es besser wird es melden
sich immer mehr zum impfen an dies ist
sehr sehr positiv und ich glaube der
trend geht weiter übrigens auch von den
maßnahmen her weil wir schon eher mit 2g
begonnen haben wenn sie heute
verschiedenen karten in den medien
schauen und gehört bayern und sachsen ja
zu denen die an als letzte geöffnet und
als erster die strengsten regeln gemacht
haben die allerdings bislang eine erste
wirkung haben mit dem impfen noch keine
veränderung bei der infektion also die
akzeptieren natürlich die
herausfordernde situation für ungeimpfte
auch aber wir müssen angesichts solcher
zahlen aufgrund der tatsache dass bayern
wegen seiner niedrigen impft wurden
besonders in einigen regionen dies
verbessern muss muss man sagen dass auch
die gefühle der geimpften berücksichtigt
werden müssen viele menschen sind
schlicht und einfach genervt von dieser
debatte und von den argumenten das heißt
wir müssen nicht immer nur in der
öffentlichen debatte rücksicht nehmen
auf die die ungeübt sind sondern wir
müssen auch ein bisschen rücksicht
nehmen auf denjenigen die geimpft sind
und ich sag's umgekehrt weniger
rücksicht auf die die sich ganz bewusst
nicht impfen lassen wollen weil sie
keine rücksicht auf andere nehmen wollen
wir werden jetzt über nacht und dann
morgen mit unserem koalitionspartner
wir haben uns schon vorbereitende
gespräche geführt und ich denke werden
wollen auch sehr einheitlich auftreten
können wir werden prüfen was nach dem
neuen recht alles möglich ist wir werden
überlegen was nach dem alten recht
insbesondere bis zum 15 12 möglich ist
alles was wir morgen beschließen dient
ganz bewusst für die nächsten drei
wochen hier das tempo runter zu bringen
und dann das gesundheitssystem zu
entlasten wir prüfen was nach dem alten
recht noch möglich ist weil die
verlängerung geschaffen wurde vor allen
dingen aber nach der wahrung der
verfassungsmäßigen rechte auch der
geimpften dies ist ganz entscheidend
dass das kommt der grundsatz ist aber
klar verschaffen und zwar grundlegend
kontakte reduzieren sowohl bei
veranstaltungen als auch in anderen
bereichen ich sage das ausdrücklich wird
tun das was wir tun müssen wir tun ist
in enger abstimmung nicht nur mit dem
koalitionspartner sondern auch mit den
kommunen mit denen wir eng
zusammenarbeiten aber vor allen dingen
um pflegerinnen und pfleger und
intensivmediziner zu entlasten der
dezember wird ein erneut schwerer monat
ein schwerer monat erneut die
eigenverantwortung die wir sehr stark in
den mittelpunkt gerückt haben die
letzten monate hat offenkundig nicht
gereicht dass jeder diese eigene
verantwortung entsprechend wahrgenommen
hat so dass wir jetzt die leitplanken
bestätigen müssen ich verstehe jeden der
darüber verunsichert ist oder auch
genervt aber es hilft nichts es kommt
darauf an was am ende rauskommt
und nicht was wir jetzt an weniger
möglichkeiten gerne hätten
bayern liegt an den zahn zu einen
deutlichen zahn zu wir sind auch heute
noch in enger abstimmung mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen aus sachsen was
die vorschlagen und versuchen der
situation angemessen morgen zu
entscheiden aber die sache ist ganz klar
wegducken ist keine option
zu hoffen es geht vorbei
und man muss leider aufgrund der
aktuellen situation und den zahlen alle
möglichkeiten ausschöpfen die wir haben
es geht von kontakt beschränkungen wie
gesagt über obergrenzen und auch absagen
bestimmte bereiche die wir dann morgen
noch einmal präzisieren wollen ich
möchte dem koalitionspartner auch als
tier fragen auf keinen fall vorgreifen
sondern wir wollen das morgen beheben
und das was passiert ist völlig klar
vielen dank
soweit also der bayerische
ministerpräsident und das war mit blick
auf morgen ja durchaus schon mal
interessant denn er hat gesagt bayern
wird im bundesrat zustimmen wir gehen
ins nächste bundesland nach hessen dort
regiert schwarz grün und
ministerpräsident bouffier ist natürlich
jetzt auch vor die presse gegangen und
wir sind gespannt wie er die lage
einschätzt und ob er möglicherweise auch
schon etwas übermorgen über die
bundesratssitzung sagt
parallel zu dieser konferenz heute hat
der deutsche bundestag hat das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen und
ich will zunächst einmal festhalten dass
ich diese entscheidung für falsch halte
das
jetzt in der bevölkerung der eindruck
erweckt wurde dass die epidemische lage
notlage von nationaler bedeutung dass
man das jetzt gestrichen hat das ist
genau das falsche signal wir sind genau
in einer anderen situation
die inzidenz steigen die belastungen in
den kliniken steigen und wir haben eine
ausgesprochen ernste herausforderung
deshalb das ist das falsche signal
gewesen jetzt müssen wir aber mit dieser
situation umgehen und deshalb war die
heutige konferenz
eigentlich von anfang bis ende
gezeichnet gekennzeichnet von dem
bemühen
angemessene regelungen zu finden wie wir
jetzt zwei dinge zusammenbringen zum
einen dem ausserordentlichen ernste lage
zu entsprechen und maßnahmen ins auge zu
fassen und auch zu beschließen die diese
situation
bremsen diese situation nach möglichkeit
stoppen damit diese entwicklung nicht
ständig in die falsche richtung
weitergehen und auf der anderen seite zu
versuchen das leben so weit als möglich
aufrecht zu erhalten
das bedeutet also ein höheres
schutzniveau und gleichzeitig
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen die wir
miteinander besprochen und auch
beschlossen haben jenseits aller
parteilinien war klar dass wir in eine
herausforderung sind die
und das hat herr wieder der chef des
robert koch-instituts hier gestern
gesagt noch nie so ernst war
spüren auch alle und deshalb haben wir
auch bedeutende maßnahmen miteinander
vereinbart und ich will auf einige
punkte hinweisen
zunächst einmal sind wir uns einig
geworden dass wir generell in ganz
deutschland die sogenannte zweig lösung
einführen das heißt dass wir für
genesene ungeimpfte entsprechende
möglichkeiten aufrechterhalten die
ungeimpften dann nicht mehr zur
verfügung stehen wir haben das
konkretisiert mit dem sogenannten
hospitalisierung fährt sie werden sich
erinnern dass steht im
infektionsschutzgesetz werden früher nur
die instanzen jetzt ist die grundlage
der so genannte hospitalisierung wert
und andere elemente treten dann hinzu
und wir haben sozusagen drei stufen
beschlossen die erste ist bei eine
hospitalisierung rate von 3 die zweite
dann bei 6 die dritte bei 9 jedes mal
sind dann weitere maßnahmen zu ergreifen
die kollegen in sachsen sind gerade
dabei ganz erhebliche maßnahmen zu
greifen weil die weit über diesen neuen
sind wir sind in hessen glücklicherweise
deutlich unter dem bundesdurchschnitt
wir haben heute und eine vitalisierung
wert von etwa 4,8 wir haben ja schon in
der vergangenheit in hessen dieses zweig
als option möglichkeit gehabt konnte man
wählen ob man so oder so machen will das
soll nach dem beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute mit
der bundesregierung in zukunft entfallen
es gibt dann keine wahlmöglichkeit mehr
sondern es gilt generell
2g
die nächste stufe erreicht ist das sind
dann die werte sechs hospitalisierung
rate dann tritt zu dem umstand dass
jemand genesen ist oder geimpft ist in
bestimmten bereichen noch eine weitere
voraussetzung hinzu wenn man dann der
teilnehmen will das gilt insbesondere
für die bereiche die sehr
infektionsgefährdet sind also die
klassiker die discos die bars
prostitutionsstätten und ähnliches mehr
dort kann man dann in dieser wert
erreicht ist auch als geimpfter nicht
mehr teilnehmen ohne zusätzlichen test
das ist ohne zweifel eine erschwerung
das ist auch schwierig für die
entsprechenden betriebe aber es ist das
ergebnis einer abwägung die es möglich
macht das so zu betreiben zu
veranstalten auch teilzunehmen aber eben
mit einer höheren entsprechenden
schutzverpflichtung und das wäre dann
der test wir haben und das erscheint mir
auch sehr wichtig eine ganze reihe von
dingen im weiteren beschlossen die
bisher eher streitig waren und wir
konnten den streit heute auflösen zum
beispiel ein sehr wichtiger bereich der
auch uns sehr am herzen sagte
dass wir die impfpflicht für bestimmte
beschäftigte in bestimmten einrichtungen
entsprechend vereinbart haben und auch
den bund und der bund hat es ja mit
beschlossen das muss durch bundesgesetz
geregelt werden dann auch entsprechend
aufgefordert haben das umzusetzen das
bedeutet zum beispiel dass all
diejenigen die in krankenhäusern tätig
sind in altenheimen tätig sind aber auch
in der mobilen altenpflege also überall
dort wo es eine sehr intensive
persönliche begegnung mit sehr
schutzbedürftigen menschen geht also die
brücken wollen arabien gruppe dass wir
dort sicherstellen wollen dass
diejenigen die dort arbeiten auch
geimpft sind und wir machen das nicht
nach dem motto wir nehmen jetzt eine
berufsgruppe sondern in einem
krankenhaus kanzleramt sein es kann aber
auch die pfleger sein es kann aber auch
die reinigungskraft seien alle die ihn
einrichtungen sind und in den mobilen
bereich soll das eben auch gelten ist
aus meiner sicht ein wirklich ganz ganz
entscheidender schritt der heute
geschlossen wurde wir haben darüber
hinaus uns verständigt dass wir
möglichst rasch sicherheit haben wollen
für all diejenigen die gegebenenfalls in
den nächsten wochen wirtschaftlich nur
beschränkt tätig sein können der
klassiker ist dann zum beispiel der
weihnachtsmarkt der klassiker sind
andere bereiche von veranstaltungen oder
ähnliches mehr es kann sein dass es
notwendig ist es zu beschränken wir
wollen das grundsätzlich
aufrechterhalten aber es ist
wahrscheinlich notwendig beschränkungen
vorzunehmen dann kommt es dann
gegebenenfalls auch zu wirtschaftlichen
einbußen deshalb sind wir der
überzeugung ist braucht die
wirtschaftshilfen auch in der zukunft
der amtierende bundesfinanzminister und
wahrscheinliche zukünftige kanzler olaf
scholz hat dass grundsätzlich auch
eingeräumt die situation ist allerdings
die die neue ampel mehrheit muss erst
einmal beraten was er denn nun konkret
eigentlich wollen aber ich will so viel
sagen auch für die menschen und die es
jetzt geht nach dem motto denk dir daran
was das für mich vielleicht bedeutet ja
und wir wollen das so schnell wie
möglich auf die reihe bringen möglichst
unbürokratisch wir haben alle unsere
gemeinsamen erfahrungen wie manches
lange gedauert hat wir haben vor einem
jahr wird er noch einmal hilfe
angefangen das hat dann monate gedauert
zum teil bis die leute ihr geld bekommen
das darf nicht noch mal passieren
darüber gibt es eigentlich kein streit
am ende wird man sich verständigen
müssen das ist heute als generelle
forderung beschlossen worden neben
vielem anderen mehr
soweit also volker bouffier aus dem
schwarz grün regierten hessen klar
gesagt wie er sich morgen im bundesrat
verhalten wird hat er nicht aber nachdem
in hessen ja die union mit den grünen
zusammen reagiert gibt es in solchen
fällen eigentlich die vereinbarung dass
wenn ein partner nicht einverstanden ist
sich dann der stärkere partner dann der
stimme enthält den bundesrat man wird
sehen ob das morgen so passiert also aus
bayern haben wir gehört söder wird
zustimmen von bouffier haben wir keine
eindeutige aussage gehört herr wüst hat
vorhin ja in der pressekonferenz nach
dem bund länder gesprächen gesagt dass
er das nutzung nächst einmal in seiner
koalition besprechen wird er hat eine
schwarz gelbe koalition da gilt im
prinzip der gleiche fall wie für die
schwarz grüne koalition in hessen
schauen wir einmal nach rheinland pfalz
malu dreyer die sozialdemokratische
ministerpräsidentin
ist auch vor die presse getreten und wir
sind gespannt wie sie die dinge sieht
darf ihnen mitteilen dass wir eine
außerordentlich konstruktiven gute
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hatten bund
und länder ziehen an einem strang um der
pandemie zu begegnen sie zu bekämpfen
und ich bin auch davon überzeugt dass
wir mit dem gemeinsamen vorgehen uns
auch verständigt haben so dass die
bevölkerung eine klare orientierung hat
wie es deutschlandweit in der umsetzung
weiter geht das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz ist ja im
deutschen bundestag mit breiter mehrheit
beschlossen worden und durch diese
infektionsschutzgesetz bekommen wir
maßnahmen möglichkeiten teilweise auch
instrumente einen ganzen
instrumentenkasten die es in der
vergangenheit noch nicht gegeben hat die
auch sehr weitgehend sind ich nenne
dabei natürlich 3g am arbeitsplatz was
ab mittwoch wenn das gesetz
verabschiedet wird im bundesrat in kraft
tritt ich nenne 3g im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und und das halte ich
für besonders wichtig noch zu sagen dass
wir uns jetzt verständigt haben dass wir
mit unseren eigenen rechtsverordnungen
sobald die hospitalisierung rate über
drei ist oder bei 3 ist dass wir dann
alle miteinander zweig einführen werden
was freizeitveranstaltungen kultur
hotels gastro und dienstleistungen
betrifft wobei natürlich kinder unter
zwölf aber auch diejenigen menschen die
sich nicht impfen lassen können und das
auch durch attest dann einfach zeigen
dass die ausgenommen sind in diesem fall
zweig also bundesweit immer ab eine
hospitalisierung rate von 3 ab einem
bestimmten anderen schwellenmärkten
nämlich sechs wird sie im ganzen land
also in ganz deutschland 2g plus
eingeführt werden für rheinland pfalz
bedeutet das dass wir mit der neuen
rechtsverordnung es unmittelbar umsetzen
werden weil unser land eben auch
flächendeckend was die hospitalisierung
rate betrifft bei drei sind und insofern
mir auch darunter fallen das gilt
übrigens für ganz deutschland denn
rheinland pfalz ist der insgesamt bei
den werten unter bundesdurchschnitt in
ganz vielen bereichen deshalb ist es
aber auch ein gutes eine gute sache
sagen zu können wir haben uns auch
verständigt auf einen wert wo ganz
deutschland jetzt an einem strang zieht
und sagt wir steigen um auch zweig was
freizeitveranstaltungen hotel gastro und
so weiter betrifft viele länder chefs
und chefinnen haben ja schon in der
vergangenheit maßnahmen ergriffen das
gilt auch für rheinland pfalz wir haben
ja längst zusätzliche schutzmaßnahmen
beispielsweise in den alten und
pflegeheimen wir haben tests reaktiviert
wir haben die regelung in diesem bereich
dass der mann nicht geimpft ist zweimal
geimpft ist dass man sich dann testen
lassen muss sie wissen dass wir auch die
übungszentrum hochfahren und auch die
booster impfungen beschleunigen darauf
nicht gleich nochmal zu sprechen in der
neuen corinna bekämpfung verordnung die
wir dann am ab mittwoch in kraft setzen
werden und zwar gemeinsam mit dem
inkrafttreten des neuen
infektionsschutzgesetzes war dann auch
die rechtsgrundlage unserer verordnung
ist werden wir all diese bereiche zur
umsetzung bringen ich will vielleicht
noch mal einen blick zurückwerfen
vor genau einem jahr haben wir zusammen
glaube ich auch hier nicht hier in
berlin gestanden aber vielleicht in
mainz gestanden und damals war die lage
ist so dass wir dann entschieden haben
dass viele freizeiteinrichtungen
geschlossen werden dass kontakte
reduziert werden es folgte dann der
locker und im einzelhandel und es
folgten schulschließung und es folgte
eine quälende zeit wir wollen im winter
2021 alles daran setzen dass wir eben
nicht in diese lage geraten der
unterschied zu vor einem jahr ist dass
deutschland über eine neben stoff
verfügt und viele erwachsene haben sich
ja auch längst impfen lassen das heißt
die mehrheit der bevölkerung hat einen
impfschutz sie wird nicht mehr schwer
krank hat keine schweren
krankheitsverlauf mehr sie kann sich
schützen sind trotzdem noch anstecken
und deshalb ist es für uns auch so
wichtig da komme ich gleich darauf zu
sprechen dass wir das impfen auch weiter
intensivieren wir haben trotz allem eine
hohe infektionsgefahr mick und viele
stellen sich schon die frage warum sind
eigentlich in deutschland unsere
krankenhäuser belastet und warum sind so
viele menschen auf intensivstationen
das hat zum einen vor allem damit zu tun
dass vor allem ungeimpfte lange auch
ringen um ihr leben in unseren
krankenhäusern
es sind so die gruppe der mittelalten
menschen wir haben zum zweiten weniger
pflegepersonal aufgrund der
langanhaltenden corona pandemie sind
viele viele menschen ausgepowert und
stehen einfach nicht mehr mit der
gleichen kraft und möglichkeit zur
verfügung und wir haben darüber hinaus
eben auch die situation kann ich meine
schrift nicht mehr lesen
keine operation also ja das halte ich
für rheinland pfalz noch sagen wir haben
die situation zurzeit eben den rheinland
pfalz dass wir noch keine operationen
verschieben müssen und das bedeutet eben
das in den intensivstationen eben auch
ganz menschen sind die einfach aufgrund
anderer erkrankungen auf intensiv sind
unser ziel ist es in rheinland-pfalz ich
habe eben gesagt dass wir im
bundesdurchschnitt unterhalb des
bundesdurchschnitts liegt was die
inzidenz die hospitalisierung die
intensiv belegung betrifft dass wir auch
nicht in diese lage kommen deshalb
begrüße ich das auch dass wir jetzt auf
der grundlage des neuen gesetzes ein
gemeinsames vorgehen in der ausführung
haben nämlich zweig einzuführen und
später auch zweig plus falls die zahlen
entsprechend steigen sollten wichtig ist
auch dass wir konsequent gegen die impf
fälscher vorgehen wir haben für unser
land jetzt entschieden weil im fälschung
eben kein kavaliersdelikt ist dass wir
eine sonder kontrollaktion kontroll tage
machen durch die ordnungskräfte und
durch die polizei begleitet um damit
auch deutlich zu machen dass wir es
nicht tolerieren wenn ihm ausweise
gefälscht werden das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz verstärkt an
dieser stelle auch noch mal die
regelungen und wir werden dafür sorgen
dass die kontrollen dementsprechend auch
umgesetzt werden und dass sie
funktionieren ich habe gesagt unsere
verordnung am mittwoch hand in hand mit
dem infektionsschutzgesetz die fragen ja
das ist ja noch gar nicht in kraft
jahren morgen will der bundesrat über
dieses gesetz entscheiden ich bin jetzt
sehr zuversichtlich nachdem wir sehr
intensiv sehr konstruktiv miteinander
gesprochen haben indem wir viele
maßnahmen auch verabschiedet haben die
auf der grundlage dieses gesetzes eine
rolle spielen dass wir morgen dann auch
im bundesrat das gesetz verabschieden
können
die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in malu dreyer sie
hofft also dass morgen alle zustimmen
werden und das ist auch im bundesrat
eine mehrheit für das
infektionsschutzgesetz gibt reisen wir
weiter nach sachsen-anhalt reiner
haseloff ist dort ministerpräsident
sehen wir wie ihre dinge einschätzt
wir haben wie gesagt innerhalb der
politisch nicht ganz einfachen
konstellation zumindest ein kleines
papier
erstellt was mit den beschlüssen die da
drinstehen grundlage in ganz deutschland
einheitlich ist in der umsetzung das
heißt wir haben uns darauf verständigt
dass ihr ein grundkonzept zum risiko
eindämmung und so pandemie
zurückdrängung haben was in ganz
deutschland gleichermaßen gilt das
wollten wir von anfang an weil es
wichtig ist sie wissen wir haben alleine
jeder sechste bürger und bürgerinnen die
im erwerbsleben stehen sind pendlerinnen
und pendler das heißt wir haben
verletzungen bis hinauf zur
wirtschaftlichen zusammenhängen der
tourismus fremdenverkehr all das bewegt
sich ja schließlich nicht innerhalb von
landesgrenzen wir brauchen ein
einheitliches konzept und auch
einheitliche standards wenn es darum
geht die auch maßnahmen des bundes auch
wirksam werden zu lassen so das ist erst
mal der erfolg in deutschland ein
kleines grundkonzept
wir haben uns hat auch erst einmal in
den koalitionsfraktionen bzw innerhalb
der koalition in der landesregierung
darauf verständigt dass wir dieses eines
vereins zur grundlage nehmen und
umsetzen
natürlich angepasst auf die entsprechend
auch im papier vorgesehenen spezifika
dass hier bei ihrem bundeslandes in
hamburg in einem stadtstaat zu sagen ist
es was anderes in der umsetzung als in
einem flächenland wie sachsen anhalt
also ist klar
dass ich sozusagen über den zeitlichen
ablauf der letzten vier wochen nicht
besonders glücklich bin das will ich
hier zumindestens als vertreter eines
der koalitionspartner genannt cdu
durchaus zum ausdruck bringen weil diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die wir
heute durchgeführt haben habe ich
schriftlich am 31.10 diesen jahres
beantragt beim vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
dem kollegen wüst aus nordrhein
westfalen heute ist es dann endlich dazu
gekommen zeitgleich zur bundestags
behandlung man hätte
atmosphäre sicherlich vieles günstiger
haben können aber wie gesagt
entscheidend ist wir müssen für das land
arbeiten und das land denken und sehen
wie unabhängig von der bundespolitischen
gesamtsituation wir unsere aufgaben hier
erfüllen wohl wissend dass es eine
verletzung ja auch gibt aus unserer
koalition heraus in richtung auch der
bundesebene
24 anwesenden mit akteure sozusagen sind
ja in einer neuen bundesregierung zu
erwarten und deswegen müssen wir sehen
wie wir deutschland insgesamt aus dieser
schwierigen situation herausführen das
nochmal vorangestellt was ist sozusagen
die grundkonzeption wir haben ein
maßnahmenpaket auf den weg gebracht
einzelmaßnahmen greifen nicht das haben
wir bei allen möglichen versuchen
gesehen das heißt wir brauchen ein
flächiges
einsatzkonzept über einen flächigen
ansatz der in die bereiche hinein geht
die insgesamt dazu beitragen dass die
kontakte deutlich reduziert wird
und da sprechen die fachleute von 60 bis
70 prozent wobei das sozusagen die zahl
ist die man meinen kollegen kann ich
meine entschuldigung sachsen empfohlen
hat wir wissen dass wir noch nicht auf
diesem niveau sind aber das insgesamt in
deutschland die instanzen steigen und
auch die auslastung im gesundheitswesen
und demzufolge ist das eine größe die
wir zumindest vor augen haben müssen
wenn es darum geht deutlich die kontakt
dichte runterzufahren und das
gesellschaftliche leben zu beruhigen im
sinne dessen dass es nicht zur
weitergabe des der infektions treibenden
viren kommt und dazu auch es maßnahmen
da haben wir unsere erfahrung all das
wird wie gesagt frau gerne dann noch mal
von der methodik darstellen
vom grundsatz gibt es eine
unterscheidung zwischen innen und außen
außen geht deutlich mehr als innen da
sind sozusagen jetzt die letzten die die
infektions treibern und einer weise in
konstellationen versammelt und deswegen
musste etwas geschehen und wie gesagt
näheres dazu
und wir haben weiterhin auch von der
grundkonzeption hier einfach auch zu
sehen dass die schwierigkeit der
situation in einem bundesland eindeutig
korreliert mit
der enns quote die dort ist es am
schwierigsten wo die impfquote am
niedrigsten ist die es in sachsen am
niedrigsten aber auch bei uns ist nicht
befriedigend das heißt über die
impfquote und die impfbereitschaft all
das was sie dann auch ein papier
vorfinden was wir uns vorgenommen haben
müssen wir parallel zu all diesen
maßnahmen der kontakt begrenzung bzw
auch der entsprechenden maßnahmen die
wir hier erzielen müssen entsprechend
die impfbereitschaft weiter wecken und
auch zum boostern kommen und dafür die
kapazitäten aufbauen da sind bis hin zur
finanziellen fragen und viele sachen
dort hinein gelegt
wir reisen weiter nach baden württemberg
und der ministerpräsident kretschmann
hat sich auch vor der presse geäußert da
hat er ja gestern schon darauf
hingewiesen wie ernst die lage ist und
wie ernst er das thema nimmt und welche
maßnahmen er sich für sein bundesland er
oft aber letztlich auch für das ganze
land deshalb jetzt noch einmal aus
stuttgart
die vierte corona welle trifft uns mit
brutaler wucht
die zahl der neuinfektionen ist so hoch
wie nie zuvor
und sie steigt mit jedem tag auf immer
neue höchstwerte
dabei gehen wir die berichte aus den
intensivstationen besonders nahe denn
wir laufen auf eine situation zu wie sie
in dieser pandemie noch nicht erlebt
haben mit einem personal das während der
letzten welle immer alles gegeben hat
und das auch jetzt wieder sicher
übermenschliches leisten
denn bereits heute werden etwa 450
corona patienten auf den
intensivstationen
behandelt
bereits heute arbeiten viele unserer
intensivstation am limit
bereits in wenigen wochen werden unsere
intensivstation
überlastet sein wenn es so weiter geht
deshalb habe ich die große sorge dass
wir schon bald keine
angemessene behandlung aller erkranken
mehr garantieren können warum ist die
lage so ernst
weil das delta virus hochansteckend ist
deutlich ansteckender als es die
varianten zuvor waren weil die kalte
jahreszeit wieder kommt und wir uns
nicht mehr draußen aufhalten sondern
drinnen aber der hauptgrund ist es sind
zu wenig menschen geimpft
aber allein die impfungen sind der
ausweg aus diesem ganzen schlamassel das
muss ich noch mal deutlich sagen
deswegen ist es ein echtes problem dass
deutschland bei der impfquote im
europäischen vergleich ganz hinten liegt
zusammen mit österreich und der schweiz
und das hört sich verheerend aus und
wohin das bei uns führen kann sehen wir
in österreich
dort reicht in einigen regionen die
kapazität nicht mehr um alle patienten
zu versorgen deshalb werden dort
inzwischen sogenannte trias teams
zusammengestellt die entscheiden wer die
notwendige behandlung bekommt und wer
nicht eine solche situation müssen wir
bei uns mit aller kraft vermeiden
konkret bedeutet das
erstens wir müssen im kampf nochmals
impfen und zwar egal ob erstimpfung
zweitimpfung oder auffrischungsimpfungen
den berg ist steckt seltener ansteckt
selten
ich selber viel weniger gefährdet und
vor allem er erkrankt deutlich weniger
schwer als nicht geimpfte das hilft uns
langfristig am meisten allerdings reicht
es sind der aktuellen lage nicht aus
deshalb müssen wir zweitens wieder die
kontakte reduzieren so wie wir es ja
gewohnt sind waren in langen zeiten der
pandemie
das trifft vor allem die ungeimpften
denn das virus lebt von kontakten und
nicht geimpfte geben das virus stärker
weiter als geimpfte und das müssen wir
unterbinden um möglichst schnell die
zahl der neuinfektionen zu senken
sehr geehrte damen und herren bei uns in
baden württemberg sind viele
intensivstation bereits sehr stark
ausgelastet in zehn der 44 stadt und
landkreise gibt es derzeit maximal noch
ein freies intensiv bett in sieben
weiteren kreisen sind sogar alle bitten
schon belegt deshalb gilt bei uns seit
gestern die alarmstufe für weite teile
des öffentlichen lebens gilt jetzt die
zweijährige und das bedeutet nur noch
geimpfte ungelesene haben zugang zur
kultur gastronomie freizeit und sport
darüber hinaus gibt es kontakt
beschränkungen für nicht geimpfte sie
dürfen sich allein oder als haushalt nur
noch mit einer weiteren person treffen
an den schulen gilt wieder die masten
pflicht am platz ich möchte ich
ausdrücklich sagen das sind keine
empfehlungen es sind regeln an die wir
uns alle zu halten haben
und wer sich nicht daran hält muss mit
bußgeldern rechnen
das war unsere deutschland reise nach
der bund länder sitzung die wir wollen
übertragen haben wir haben in mehrere
bundesländer geschaut um abzuschätzen
wie sich das weiter entwickelt und wie
morgen im bundesrat abgestimmt wird und
es scheint so zu sein dass es im
bundesrat morgen eine mehrheit geben
dürfte
mehr zu all diesen themen um 23 uhr in
der sendung der tag schon vorher um
22.15 befasst sich auch die runde mit
diesem thema der titel am limit was
bringt der korona gipfel und auch jetzt
gleich noch vor der tagesschau sehen sie
hier einen corinna nachgehakt und ich
wünsche ihnen weiterhin spannenden
fernsehabend und zach bis später
[Musik]